[Música]
i e ii começa porque ele é o líder certo
que nem legal acho certo essa seu onze
anos mais precisamente há seis anos
atrás
hoje eu tenho 17 essa garota curiosa e
que achava super interessante encontrar
as minhocas é no quintal de casa e
mostrar na webcam do computador é essa
garota que está aqui é a garota que é
apaixonada pelo pai das folhas pelo
vaivém das ondas do mar e pelo brilho
das estrelas e essa mesma garota que
está falando aqui é essa menina do vídeo
só que aos poucos ela foi crescendo um
pouco nessa parte
lógico que ainda tem muito para aprender
bom essa garota que é apaixonada pela
natureza é também apaixonado por uma uma
outra coisinha que tem tudo a ver com
aquele vídeo ao lado começo que a
ciência talvez tenha sido porque o meu
vôo quando eu era pequena sonhava comigo
fazer a lição de casa de ciências e
começou a estimular seu lado em mim
ou talvez tenha sido por causa do roubo
de ficar tudo que eu fiz quando últimos
oito anos o projeto boné de escola mas
eu lembro dele até hoje e foi
extremamente marcante e talvez tenha
sido meu vôo tenha sido esse projeto
tenha sido o amor pela natureza e tudo
isso junto que tenham feito chegar aqui
hoje e que ainda vai fazer o caminhar
com certeza muito mais dentro dessa área
essa ciência junto com essa natureza foi
crescendo dentro de mim e ainda vem
florescendo cada dia mais eu chamo essa
pessoa que habita dentro do meu corpo de
cientistas em diploma está no 3º ano do
ensino médio de problema é uma coisa que
falta uns anos ainda é chegar a 1 mas o
importante é a partir do cientista a
partir de uma metodologia científica
básica de encontrar um problema todos
são capazes
de desenvolver testes todas são capazes
novamente e de a partir desses testes
desenvolver soluções e alternativas e
foi isso que começou a crescer dentro de
mim essa coisa aqui qualquer um daqui
pode fazer uma ciência básica e na
ciência básica ela começou a ser mais
estimulado ainda quando entrei no ensino
médio
então eu tô lá na escola estadual culto
à ciência e quando entrei lá dois anos
atrás eu conheci duas orientadora que
foram extremamente importantes
é no trabalho que realiza hoje um
trabalho de pesquisa que vai lhes hoje
que aloísio a professora de química e
cláudia professora de biologia
essas duas junto com uma aluna que é
mega curiosa e que mega gosta de
ciências começou a desenvolver projetos
é o melhor é um projeto específico
eu já sabia que eu ia fazer um projeto
relacionado ao meio ambiente mas não
sabia sobre exatamente o que o ano
passado quando assistir um vídeo
horrível de uma tartaruga que tiram a
tartaruga da água ela tem um canudinho
preso no nariz
talvez eu tenho visto um vídeo que
realizou e esse vídeo mexeu muito comigo
e daí eu falei sobre isso mesmo que eu
vou falar
é isso que está me incomodando então vou
colocar essa ferida e eu vou atrás disso
e foi aí que eu comecei a desenvolver o
be o canudo
ano passado eu desenvolvesse eu comecei
a desenvolver esse projeto se chama
projeto de pré iniciação científica e e
civil canudo que eu tenho hoje é um
canudinho biodegradável e comestível
feita à base de inhame então é o
tecnicamente já tem uma solução para
aquilo que eu vi no vídeo mas como se
isso fosse o suficiente é muitas outras
coisas me incomoda eu tenho certeza que
ainda faria muitos projetos na área
mas a questão é que o bill canudo
começou a ser desenvolvido com testes na
cozinha de casa no laboratório da escola
e hoje eu tenho uma parceria do
instituto de química da unicamp também
para desenvolver mais testes ainda
porque o importante mesmo é que lá no
começo eu falei que eu não queria que as
tartarugas passassem por aquela situação
o canudinho preso no país
e é isso que está fazendo eu acredito sc
tentar aperfeiçoar cada vez mais o meu
projeto mas mais ainda do que isso o be
o canudo não é só um canudinho ou não é
só um outro potencial que esse
bioplástico que eu desenvolvi é possa
ser a idéia é que quando você recebesse
canudinho no seu copo você gera
estranheza na cabeça sabe quando uma
coisa pensada um canudinho de plástico e
daí de repente é um canudinho que dá pra
comer né que coisa estranha você pode
comer pastel de uva framboesa limão e
tem aquela coisa está no seu copo e que
agora você pode comer só fica curioso
porque o que é estranho gera curiosidade
o que é curioso porque gera curiosidade
faz com que você procure mais sobre
aquilo e procurando mais a gente vai
cair dentro de uma problemática que não
queria e não são só os canudinhos mas
não são só os canudinhos plásticos são
todos os pais que vão parar nos oceanos
sabe o que me assusta é que me apavora é
saber que a onu estima que até 2050
tenham mais plástico do que peixes no
oceano
isso é horrível e foi exatamente essa
sensação de culpa que vem quando eu
assisti o vídeo e que vem toda vez que
eu repito isso porque não tem como a
gente sentar e ouvir o canudo mais do
que um canudinho
é uma prova de que dá pra gente começará
a desenvolver alternativas e começar a
refazer os hábitos hábitos tão pequenos
quanto um canudinho e não dá pra gente
começar a desenvolver tudo isso na
cozinha de casa sem um diploma talvez ao
certo e dentro de toda essa ideia eu
sempre passa uma mensagem de que o lixo
é nossa responsabilidade
isso foi uma coisa que me moveu de
memória até hoje
então a gente não está isento do copinho
plástico que a gente hoje ele vai
continuar existindo na natureza por
muito tempo e isso é extremamente
frustrante e isso é nossa culpa e eu
tenho certeza absoluta de que cada um dá
aqui se cada um fizer uma sozinha pelo
planeta
uma tartaruga ou um peixe ou algum
animal que seja até a saúde de vocês
é isso vai fazer toda a diferença mesmo
que seja uma pequena ação e foi isso que
eu quis foi que eu venho tentando
desenvolver com miguel canudo
então em conjunto com o canudinho eu
tenho também as redes sociais
o instagram facebook o twitter do be o
canudo e lá exatamente essa ideia que o
pago gente é um canudinho apenas mas é
uma menina de ensino médio que
desenvolve um projeto de ciências nas
medidas que ela que ela vai tentando
então uma coisa não dá certo foi
adaptando na cozinha de casa mesmo eu
não tinha balança
não sei se vocês já fizeram o trabalho
de pesquisa mas gente dizer sem balança
uma coisa muito difícil mas a nota as
coisas que você usa energia balança eu
fui atrás não tinham abortado da escola
uma balança preciso do dinheiro que eu
precisava e e daí parece que nada vai
dar certo mas quando a gente fala de
ciências nos resultados que dão errado
também são respostas e é por isso que eu
falo que em ciência é pra todo mundo
a ciência é sim pra as mulheres que têm
menos de 30% dos artigos científicos no
mundo fascinados por mulheres
então a ciência para as mulheres às
vezes é pras meninas e pode ser ciências
humanas pode ser cinza exatas biológicas
o importante é encontrar um problema uma
coisa que te incomoda
pegar aquela ferida e atrás daquilo
porque só assim que a gente vai começar
a resolver os problemas 1 a 1 mesmo que
eles sejam tão pequenos quanto um
canudinho e a idéia de ciências em uma
rede também está presente dentro das
redes sociais do be o canudo no sentido
de que é bom a gente está falando do
século 21 a gente é basicamente tudo
mobilidade social e foi uma força enorme
assim quando eu falei a votar esse
projeto vou divulgar e isso agrega tanta
gente agrega todos profissionais e as
pessoas se interessam tanto e aquilo é
só uma motivação a mais para cada dia eu
falar beleza se esse é o problema de
hoje vou tentar resolver
é por isso que eu compartilho com parte
dos estados errado
eu compartilho os resultados que deram
certo porque compartilhando eu aprendo
com mais pessoas e no final isso que
importa o que importa gente porque a
ciência é feita pra gente
se ela ficasse no meu laboratório ou se
ela ficasse na minha cozinha de casa
eu não quero aqui hoje e com certeza
vocês não tenham a chance de estar sendo
convidados literalmente convidados que
vocês quiserem depois pode chamar pelas
redes sociais para falar como eu comece
porque eu também não sei como é que
começa ainda não sei como começa mas
convidados a fazer um projeto um projeto
de qualquer área
mas um projeto que incomode vocês porque
se incomoda porque tem o que fazer a
respeito disso e que o be o canudo é
apenas um degrau na enorme escadaria da
luta contra os plásticos mas que mesmo
sendo um degrau é importante que a gente
suba ele e subindo esse degrau eu também
deixa a escada livre para quem puder
agregar para quem quiser entender mais
do assunto porque afinal sem ser feita
pra gente e quando se trata ainda de
ciências na área da sustentabilidade
se não for a consciência ambiental que
vai salvar eu não sei o que será
porque é muito importante que todo mundo
esteja aqui
entendo que o lixo não responsabilidade
e que a menina à escola pública pode
fazer ciência assim que vocês resgatem
os cientistas curiosos de quem enxerga
problemas que existem dentro de vocês
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]